hey guys my name is just it is the 16th
of May today and this is your monday
edition of games but nice square enix
have announced that they're
super-popular japan only smartphone game
Final Fantasy brave xvs is on its way to
the west the term boast role-playing
mobile game has already reached 6
million downloads in Japan the official
description calls for players to make
their way through various types of
dungeons to search for items collect
kill uncover hidden paths and venture
near outs final fantasy brave xbs also
features characters from the main series
here you can use in battle even though
it's not out until summer you can
pre-register on their websites if you
like and receive special in-game items
think you do sir Hideo Kojima has talked
more about that mascot you probably
spotted in the Kadima productions logo
Tajima recently revealed that the
armored skull logo is in fact just the
head of a full body a body that belongs
to a fella by the name of the lewodan he
also posted a Twitter poll asking what
people thought Luden's was wearing the
current frontrunner is an armored suit
if you're really into the logo you're in
luck as kijima says a bigger version of
Luden's will be out eventually kosmos
currently teamed up with sony to make a
new action game for ps4 and PC finally a
little bit of movie news IGN has been
told that sixty-five percent of the
upcoming Assassin's Creed movie will be
set to be in the present day with thirty
five percent in 15th century Spain the
present-day segment of the assassins
creed games are generally far from fan
favorite parts but that didn't matter
too much since the focus was very much
on the historical period soon to be
assassin Michael Fassbender explained
the film's different focus by saying
there are certain things that we
absolutely want to respect in the game
but this isn't a video game that we're
me
okay we're trying to make a cinematic
experience so there are new things that
we have to introduce film opens on
december twenty more let me know down in
that comment section what hopes you have
for the assassins creed movie you should
have said by gamespot we've got stories
on Pokemon go and the warcraft movie
that is everything I had a few today as
always let me know what mattered to you
and I will see you again tomorrow